you're going to be working with the
number one choreographer in red shore
city yuck that is rubbish so bad wow
he's freaking me out
tippitos i don't see your typical
matthew you've been in so many roles
that i have loved over the years but i
gotta say playing a koala bear salesman
named buster
my favorite wanted to know yeah
how do you feel about koalas and like
have you gotten to know more about these
creatures
i spent some time in australia where
they have koalas i've seen and been
around koalas in the wild
they're incredibly boring animals
they do nothing
they're cute in a snapshot
and that's it
you can look at them for days there is
no action scene
so
if you go see a koala and you get a good
view and the light's nice and you focus
for 10 seconds you can move on because
they're not going to do anything else
so
buster's the most active koala that i've
that probably there is on the planet in
the universe um because koalas are not
like buster at all yeah it's so true
they sleep like 18 hours a day and
buster has this unrelenting optimism my
favorite part in the film is when
buster's told he's never gonna make it
in the big city and i was curious did
anyone ever say that to you when you
were starting out as an actor did you
ever feel that way
no one ever said it
they said things like you're gonna need
to change your name your name's too hard
to pronounce
succeed you need to change your name and
i was like
well that's non-negotiable
then i won't make it if that's why if
that's the reason i don't make it then
then i didn't pull it off um
no one ever said you're not gonna make
it
um there was a lot of i can't believe
you're doing that i can't believe you
drove west i can't believe you're
packing up your u-haul with 2 000 bucks
and driving out west
to go try and pull it off
but no one ever said you couldn't do it
did you ever feel like you couldn't
no
wow
if i did i squashed that thought so
quickly yeah
because i knew there was nothing
constructive about the thought i never i
didn't know but i didn't know what
there's so many forms what you could
call succeeding in the business would be
i'm still going through different
formations of what am i calling
succeeding in this business
i mean i just wanted to
be in front of the camera helping tell
stories yeah in whatever way i could and
then
i got very fortunate early on my first
two auditions
in hollywood i got them
wow that pisses some people off
you know they're like you sob but it
happened yeah um
you know i hustled my way pulled some
buster moon moves to get a few other
rolls where i
laid out there and wrote some checks
like one truck of cash wow but bet on it
and said i'm gonna take a chance and
pulled pulled a few of those off i
gambled
um
i hustled
um
and then tried to do once i was in
try to do my best to
preserve what i have
what i had but also not just be safe
with it to still keep taking chances and
say well just
keep doing what you if you can do what
you love to do and you can do your best
at it if that sustains me then that
sustains me and if it doesn't at least
i'll know i know why i did that i know i
chose that role i know why i took that
job i had an experience when i started
dealing with the uh the process
more than being given a damn about the
result i got a lot more results yeah
i love how do you squash those thoughts
and like get past that negativity on the
on the way through the math
they there's not one constructive thing
about them there's no
asset to the thought
there's
it's nice to be introspective it's nice
to have doubts
it's nice to go hmm how could i improve
but to go
to use the words i can't to think you
can't pull something off that you really
love to do
i don't see i don't see there's any math
that adds up to that ever being an asset
unless
it pisses you off
because rage can make some things happen
working against something like taking
revenge against that thought right
to eliminate that thought because you
hate that thought so much that can be an
asset yeah but i love what you said it
the doubt it's like math it's not
serving you and i feel like your sort of
guts and that inner knowing that you
have like about your own career really
shines through through buster and what i
love about voice acting is there's
nothing self-conscious about it right
like you can be in pajamas so can you
set the stage for us and tell us what
the setting was like and what you wore
from stepping into business i did it
from my studio in austin texas
uh in your house
yeah nice at my office
um
i don't i mean i kind of one that's one
of the great things you don't even have
to think about what you're wearing so i
don't know what the hell i was wearing
um didn't care
don't need to look in the mirror when
you're doing voice voice work here's the
great thing and you said it there's
nothing self-conscious about it try and
screw up
you can't
say the line in spanish say it backwards
say it forward whisper it yell it
whatever do what you the digital tape is
rolling it's not costing anything
try it and sometimes coming off a
mistake
will provide the chuckle
that leads into the next read that is
that's the one wow you know
i love that just go for it and you were
doing it at home your kids are at home
and i know they were a huge fan of their
papa being in the first film did they
give you any advice feedback while you
were recording at home for this one they
did they did when they snuck in there
they let them listen and then my
daughter vita got a couple lines in this
in this movie and then garth gave him a
tour in france the studio of how the
movie's getting made and everything um
so they were more involved in the
process of making this one than
than the first one wow did you listen to
any music to get into buster to get in
the mood for this song
for sing too no once i found the music
of who he is and the music of how he
attacks life and approaches
conflict and tries to overcome things
i tapped into that music of him in the
first one wow now when i first started
to go back and do sing two i had to go
back and watch the first one again
just to find that music again and once i
found his music
that's really like his approach
an attack on things is different than
mine my voice builds down
sort of relaxing on the end
busters is always going up yeah gotta do
this gonna make it happen so he's always
moving forward always on the outro on
the extroverted side to make it happen
to inspire or take action which is
different than my than my uh my rhythm
or my music but so as soon as soon as i
i tap back into it as soon as it caught
my ear i love it yeah you have to like
almost like jump up and be like physical
with that stuff yeah bring it up because
i'm the same i would break a sweat in
the in the recording session
i love that best workout in the game so
i'm so curious to know what was your
number one listen to song of the year
i'll tell you this i've been listening
to a lot of chuck berry um
wow a lot of checks just
let the kids hear another another era
another guitar
another version of rock and roll it's
hard to find good rock and roll these
days it is and
i miss good rock and roll
i miss the cult i miss ac dc i miss the
chuck berry um
i've also been listening a lot of dylan
who
just cracks me up
he's a great comedian yeah yeah whatever
podunk town they crawled out of that's
where they belong
[Music]
we cannot let that bully steal our hopes
and dreams guts
faith these are the things you need now
everyone's posting on social their top
stream song of the year what was your
number one song song of the year yeah
that you listened to the most this year
oh man let me like pull up my spotify
i'm like what have i been listening to
i
honestly i've been really obsessed with
this artist uh named yebba
recently and she she like kind of put
out her album more recent so it wasn't
like all year because it just came out
but um she's amazing she was like the
most inspiring album to me this year i'm
now gonna yeah yeah yeah yeah
um i'm trying my year was so strange
remember what i was listening to this
year
um
gosh it's it's hard to say i feel like
saying soundtrack what exactly no i feel
like i
just i listen to
a lot of i'm trying to like think what i
like read i feel like i've been
listening like comfort music
um i feel like i've been listening to
like the fuji's again
by the way i think we're going on tour
oh you heard it here at first okay i
know i think you guys are announcing it
they are i think oh my gosh i am there i
meet you
my dream um yeah i've been just going
back to the basics and the last two
years i think i've just been listening
to and any every like comforting thing
from my like yeah from my youth yeah
well this the music in this movie is
really comforting like you leave this
film and you're just like yeah like i
was like playing shawn mendes on the way
home and i was thinking about how it's
called sing and i wanted to ask the both
of you why do you sing and like how has
it changed your life
for me
i can't picture
my life without singing without music
really in general i think
like whenever i'm asked like what would
you do if you weren't a singer i'm i'm
immediately like well it would still be
something in music i guess it just
wouldn't be singing because i think it's
just so ingrained and so embedded
uh in in my life in my family's life too
it was just such a part of my childhood
so
singing is yeah it's kind of it's
everything i think i have to remind
myself too of like you're that's not
your whole identity you know i think as
performers it's easy to like latch on to
that and be like that's that's the scary
thing it's like i'm i'm just a performer
like that's where you get your
self-worth and i think that's where it
can get
uh just like unhealthy it's like you
have to remember like no you're you're
like a whole person you're deserving
just as you are without any of that
stuff and i'm getting really deep but um
but yeah to answer your question it's
it's a huge part of my life i love that
i contain multitudes what about you
scarlett i i grew up i mean i grew up
with watching a lot of musicals um like
rogers and hammerstein musicals and judy
garland musicals and that's where i
discovered like my
passion in performing and acting and you
know i didn't know what it was
exactly and it's been a really
interesting
journey to continue
growing as a as an actor but um
certainly singing when i was younger
singing dancing
acting acting for stage all that stuff
was just a humongous part of my
pleasure you know in my form like the
way i express myself and what i did
after school and like what i you know
it was a passion um and then that led me
to
where i am now which is singing a
youtube song in a movie
yeah what was it like singing youtube
songs and what was it like hearing it
back um very surreal it's like
when garth told me i was singing stuck
in a moment and then they were like
we're sending over the demo i was like i
don't need the demo i know the song
um it's my like 13 year old dream come
true
um and uh yeah it's i mean we recorded
it in such isolation that in my mind
like i didn't really think about it that
much because i was like
excited to see people like in the
recording studio which were like behind
four panes of glass and then um and i
was just thinking okay i'll just like
i've been seeing it in my car and i'm
gonna sing it you know and record it and
just didn't feel
i didn't think about like the
what the
that the general population would then
be
you know hearing it all together or how
it would sound with bono it's just now
i'm like i'm starting to get nervous
about it but it yeah to me at the time
it just seemed like oh yeah i
of course i got this i know this song
but i
yes it's it's it's very surreal did you
talk to bono or did he talk to you after
listening to your rendition of i still
haven't found what i'm looking for uh i
did i did i did yeah
well as you guys have known each other
for a while we have yes we've known each
other for a long time we're totally
besties
um with the fuji's and we're all going
on tour um no
[Laughter]
no he he he did text me uh but i it was
just i think because at the time it was
such a secretive thing that like he was
gonna be doing in and that we got these
youtube songs and that i just didn't
feel like i could really reach out i
just didn't know who knew what of course
he knew he texted you
but you didn't take it i probably didn't
text him back
that's such a rock star move it's just
too cool no i probably was just
terrified
but he didn't say anything to you after
hearing it he did he did and i think i
probably i probably forgot to respond
because i was cute i'm so scared bono if
you're watching this
well that's how i get it somebody gives
me a compliment
go away don't look at me
i know you turn into meena right oh yeah
the ears which i wanted to ask you about
because it's interesting when you said
it was very like an insular experience
in the beginning i know that you
recorded a lot of this stuff from your
home studio because a lot of it was in
quarantine how did that lend itself to
like mina's shyness
well i felt i felt i mean i think there
was like one
session that we actually yeah we did do
like from home because i i was like you
know i have a studio like i didn't want
to like you know have have to wait super
long so i just kind of offered it i was
like i could record stuff if you guys
want and so we did it'd be interesting
actually to find out like which actual
parts were done
from my studio i don't know how i would
be able to figure that out but
um but it was cool just being at home
you know like in my sweats and even even
when we would go in you know to record
parts in in their studio it was just
like relaxing i think just kind of
echoing what she said it's like you feel
like safe and like it's not really a big
deal it's like we're just singing some
songs and we're just being shy and you
know saying lines and garth jennings are
our directors just makes it so
comfortable and easy so then
seeing it all come together it's like
wait we did that like that's what we
made so it's just it's this really
surreal thing getting to see uh the
final result of just all that hard work
you know hard work mostly on on their
part the people actually animating and
everything but yeah it's really cool
you will never be great johnny
reese congratulations on this film you
know how people have been posting on
social media their most listened to song
of the year yeah what was your number
one song oh it's really dorky what is it
i swear i didn't post it
i listened to like rainforest sounds
while i sleep that was my most listened
to
you just like play it all night that's
amazing i do
i love that it really helps i play white
noise all night and i'm like is this
normal was ever a role you had in your
career that you were scared to take at
first but now you're really glad you did
so many um
the two that come to mind were um
playing june carter cash and walk the
line was really scary to me because i'd
never sung on film before so i trained
for six months but still we got to our
performance days and i wanted to throw
up because i was so nervous
and the other one is um doing the movie
wild
definitely that was the most physically
challenging movie i've ever done walking
a thousand miles on the pct alone with
this giant backpack and there was a lot
of really like
just stuff in there that i was scared to
do but it was really a great sense of
accomplishment when i was able to do it
i remember reading that you were like i
had to do so much on my own in that
movie yeah which is how did you push
through those obstacles and just like go
for it in both of those roles yeah i
mean for wild i'm such a performer
that's so verbal and there was almost no
dialogue yeah so so much of my movies
have been made me talking in a hundred
miles an hour and then i had nothing and
no one to talk to
and it was nerve-racking to be honest to
just be alone on film yeah but getting
through it and i was so passionate about
cheryl straight's story was um
was real
i don't know it just it really centered
me in a different way as an actor and
made me feel like i could accomplish
different kinds of roles yeah which you
have in common with rosita yeah and
rosita has 25 kids yeah he's balancing
like family and going after her dreams
i'm just thinking that's a lot of food
and that's a lot of laundry yeah like 25
kids that's a lot of that's just
logistics like you're running an army
well you have a family and you're
following your dreams so how do you
balance i have three kids sometimes it
feels like an army
[Laughter]
especially like when we go we travel
anywhere it's like there's a lot of us
there's a lot of luggage
but um
yeah i think this character really
i just love rosita because she's a mom
and she has dreams and you know she
hasn't stopped being human just because
she has children right and i think it's
really cool that her husband supports
her dreams and
and helps encourage her and i always
love that they incorporate the kids
being excited when she performs it makes
me so happy yeah how do you strike that
balance because i feel like so many
people watching this are going to relate
to that right it's not just like moms
it's anyone we're always trying to
balance like work life and our personal
lives so how do you find that balance
because you do so much yeah i mean for
me my kids always come first but i love
my work and they know that i love my
work and i
you know they are really supportive even
sometimes it's hard when i travel or i'm
gone for a while i also have an
incredible husband who is so supportive
so nurturing so encouraging and is
probably my biggest fan so that really
helps i think it's hard being a mom um
anyway because you have these feelings
of being torn at the same time you know
wanting to be home and wanting to pursue
your dreams so i think this character is
really going to resonate with a lot of
people yeah and i love that because
sometimes people feel guilty and it's
like no you don't have to feel guilty
you know like you can do it yeah i know
it's something odd about you know every
time you're away from your kids you just
you feel guilty but um it's very real
right but we still have to remember that
we're human beings at the end of the day
and it's so important to encourage women
to dream big yeah and i think you do
that through rosita in this film because
you're not only an actress you're also a
producer so i'm curious how do you think
buster is doing as a producer in this
film like what is he doing really well
you know what he knows all his players
and he's always encouraging them and
that's what i love about buster moon is
he's just he's almost like the greatest
coach is that do you feel like you bring
that a lot in the projects that you do
i do i've had to learn to be a producer
you know it wasn't my first career it's
been kind of a second chapter for me and
i love it i love in finding out what
people's real strengths are and putting
great teams together is one of my
favorite things to do well thank you for
doing it because we all love watching
everything
out into the world it is so good it
makes me so happy i'm so lucky you have
the greatest job ever you you really do
if you could make anything that you've
done before into a musical that isn't
already a musical
what what what film would you make into
a musical hmm
i mean
maybe election i think that'd be funny
um cruel intentions they made that a
musical and i went to see it it was off
like on the theater like way on the east
side of la it was so funny
and that 90s music was so fun
so that was definitely a cool one oh i
love that all here's matthew is lauren
did you ever get to did you get to work
with him actually we've done three
movies together every single movie we're
never in the same
place
we did a movie called mud together but
we were never in the same set and then
we did these two movies sing one and
sing two and we were talking yesterday
we're like we gotta do a real movie
together
dude just be too fun we're really good
friends yay and our our families are
really good friends i love that i've
noticed that you sing another taylor
swift song in this film did you get to
call taylor or ask her about it i did
tell taylor i was like girl
we're just
putting another one of your songs in our
movie but i'm just so in awe of
everything she's done and the other
thing i think is really cool about
taylor is first of all she's so
outspoken and it's amazing and she's so
infinitely creative but also she's
inspired so many young women to write
their own music
and i think that's that's really cool
yeah i agree thank you for olivia
rodrigo i know right olynyk
so many others is laura dern answering
her facetimes now girl
that large urn does not pick up enough
she picks up like every like seventh
call but
no i don't know you know people
the internet is coming for her
do you think it's an aries thing because
i'm also so impatient it's my pet peeve
when people are posting on instagram and
they don't answer my phone i'm so
impatient it's really a problem that's
what i'm gonna really work on those are
my that's my new year's resolution be
more patient with laura dern
we just gotta be brave now wrong again
again this movie it was the best rock
concert i have ever been to for the
least amount of money
[Laughter]
i was cheap but cheerful thank you it's
cheap and cheerful it was so good you
are the writer and director of this film
you must listen to so much music yes so
i'm so curious to know what was your
number one listen to song of the year
oh
do you know i know that because it was
on my spotify although i have spotify
and itunes i don't know what it is on
itunes
but on spotify i'm pretty sure it was um
the um a hero's death by fontaine's dc
euro's death by font why'd you listen to
that
it's amazing yeah and if you're looking
for kind of like a get up get started
song
it's just relentlessly positive but also
kind of aggressive
wow i love that track i can't quite
you'll check it out when you get back i
will you know when i left the theater
watching this movie i was blasting shawn
mendes because that song just makes you
i love that song yeah there's nothing
holding you back yeah i was so curious i
wanted to ask you do you
do you hear a song and you're like this
has to be in the movie and right around
it or do you start with the writing
person usually usually the latter as in
writing first and then finding a song
but then there are a couple of songs
that i've known for years where like i
have to find a place with one of those
with soyo
i love sawyer by bombay stereo and um
and we kept trying to find it places for
it i don't normally do that but
and then and then when we had this big
kind of chase sequence towards the end
of act two it's an escape sequence yeah
it's like ah that's where it goes and
once we put it in and also worked with
an orchestra and a choir to sort of
build on it oh man that song means the
world to me i love it you're killing it
this movie just gives you all the feels
in so many ways it's like i can't even
believe that you were able to top the
first thing i mean you already had a
seller cast and now you're adding people
like pharrell and bono what was it like
casting bono it was great
i mean it's sort of surreal isn't it
that we're even talking about this but
yeah no he said he's been a uh that u2's
music means the world to me
so to to be working with him and their
songs
to serve this kind of very emotional
story that really is as good as it gets
yeah
how did you go about casting him
it literally was our dream
first and only choice you know we we had
this idea for a character that he was
this legendary rock star iconic but he'd
been a recluse for 15 years
he was a lion
and he and bono had seen the first film
and and when he saw the design and what
the characters sort of journey was he
just connected with it and called up and
we had a conversation about music and
oh it's just lovely and and he just
just
came on board and and even wrote a new
song for us i didn't even ask for it he
just did it he was like he was so
passionate about the idea of music
saving someone's life
because he feels like his own life was
saved by music it means the world to him
so he wrote this song and it's really
beautiful and
staggered by
you know by the final result he was
amazing it is staggering that's a great
word uh one of my favorite characters is
actually a character that you voice not
only do you write and direct this but
you voice miss crowley i love how you
use her eye as a storytelling device the
gloss eye yeah very useful i'm like
how did garth come up with that and is
she inspired by anyone in your life
she's not no one actually in my life but
certainly characters like there's a
character in england from an old tv
comedy series
played by julie walters called mrs oval
used to be this old older lady come in
with a tea trolley
and um i loved her and all kinds of kind
of
daughtery characters i just love
i don't know where the glass eye comes
from i don't know
i'm just a bit strange i guess that just
seemed like a natural idea but it was
great to sort of in the first film that
i actually is part of the plot in this
one it just keeps doing all kinds of
weird things it's used as a wheel
it's you know it falls out and it gets
replaced by an apple
uh it's you know the bono's character
gets to give it back to you know it's
it's it's moved gets it gets a lot of
has its own journey that eyeball yeah
honestly i would watch a spin-off called
miss crowley's eyeballs yeah speaking of
sing two's gonna be
massive i think even bigger than sing
one how many sing stories do you want to
tell like have you thought of what well
you would write for sing three or sing
four it could be a scene three sing four
scene five sing six sing seven six eight
sing eight yeah see nine scene ten it'd
be like the kids version of movies yeah
i mean you'd skip thirteen because you
know yeah no you could never do that
vibes but but no i think otherwise it
could go on forever yeah have you
thought of like a sing three or four
there's an idea for it but i wouldn't be
doing it i would take a back seat and
let someone else drive that one why why
it's time to do something else yeah yeah
also it's good to let other people do
stuff like like breathe new energy new
perspectives into it what do you want to
do now live action film i'm dreaming
about my next project yeah live action
sing in vegas not quite
yeah yeah
this movie is so much about you know
it's just bigger in so many ways bigger
cast
singing i know it's nuts it's a bigger
show
what was the biggest thing you took away
from this movie personally the biggest
thing i took away well i was just so
happy at the end the most profoundly
moving
thing about the whole process is that
the feeling that audiences get at the
end is everything i hope for and that's
a that's a big deal when you're making
something like this over so many years
and it's so fragmented that when it when
it's all put together that it really
does give you the feelings that we
wanted people to experience and not just
in the theater but take away with them
yeah you know you leave with that
feeling yeah that's kind of
that's the that's the biggest thing
that's the thing i'm most proud of yeah
that feeling is there at the end i
always feel like i resonate with
johnny's storyline the most in the first
one in this one how do you pick like
what struggle or what the story arc is
going to be for each character well
i don't know how that started there
always these characters discussions with
chris miller dandry always begin as like
wouldn't it be great if or oh i could
imagine this they're very sort of
playful chats yeah and um
it we just wanted to take johnny up a
notch and like see him dancing like see
him really performing do you know me and
that noise was the sound of all the rain
in california falling at once around us
this is so cool yeah wasn't that great
yeah for a moment there you and i were
like are we just gonna just sail away on
the way did you cue that i didn't kill
you it was like magical
you're like bust your moon right now
you're just like
was there is there a character in sing
that is just the most fun to direct
oh there what you mean the actor or the
or the character
the actor they're all very funny and
delightful honestly they are so
different as well if we had like lots of
people of the same kind of personality
it would be different but they're all so
different matthew's energy is totally
different to say scarlet's personality
but they all have this really unique way
of just coming in and owning that
character and then there are certain
people that are just so funny i can
barely i can't actually be in the room
with them because i'll ruin the tape
like nick croll or eric andre you can't
stick around when they're doing their
thing because they're just too funny
i don't suppose any of you can tap dance
huh
you